(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] It's 1991, and the world
is introduced to a new TV show.
It's about two brothers,
with the same name.
Pete and Pete was an
absurdist, surreal show
shot in a very ordinary
looking suburb in New Jersey.
- We're here in the site of the old
Pete and Pete house from season two.
I'm Michael Maronna, and I played big Pete.
- And I'm Danny Tamberelli,
and I played little Pete.
- [Michael] We haven't
been here in 20 plus years
and it's, it's kind of a time machine.
- [Narrator] This typical New Jersey house
was the backdrop for the adventures
of the eccentric Wrigley family.
- Petunia was my beloved tattoo.
Dance, señorita, dance.
No one knows how I got it at age seven,
and I believe when we did the shorts,
it was on this arm and then at some point,
it switched to this arm.
I had to start showering with Saran Wrap
on my arm during the week because
they didn't want to have
to keep touching it up
and making it better.
So, I had a stinky right
arm for three seasons.
- [Narrator] One of the more bizarre parts
of the show was Artie,
a reoccurring character
who served as a constant
reminder to viewers
that you can't always
ask for an explanation.
- I believe that Artie was a figment
of our imaginations, but he
was a hell of a hallucination
because even the adults
believed that he was there.
(laughs)
- True.
Artie is, of course, the
strongest man in the world.
- Artie, the strongest man.
- [Danny] He moved the
foundation of our house,
- [Michael] an inch to the left.
- [Danny] He ran very fast.
- [Michael] He's eaten
several origami stars
that were headed for his head.
- I mean, who wouldn't want to have
a personal superhero
with them at all times,
as your best friend?
I would.
I had it.
- Artie, the strongest man in the world.
- We are not brothers biologically.
- We are fake TV brothers.
Food poisoning?
That's a triple u-ey
- Unusual, unpredictable, undetectable.
- I didn't hang out with Dan much
in the years immediately
following Pete and Pete.
- We are brothers in a weird way.
- Spiritual, we had a spiritual bond.
- We do a podcast together,
that's an important thing.
- Dan and I record a podcast called
The Adventures of Danny and Mike.
- So we see each other quite often
and boy are we still fake TV brothers.